Thank you so much for
that introduction, Hadley.
It is such a
pleasure to be here.
Max and I are really excited
to be talking to you today
about machine learning and
software for machine learning.
This talk, the
topic is not so much
going to be about the math
of statistical modeling
or new methods for
machine learning.
What we want to talk
to you here today about
is applied machine learning, how
you as a modeling practitioner
get on that road, that
road from model development
through to model deployment.
As we're here together and we
talk about being this road that
we are on.
We think this trip
down this road
is going to be better
if we all go together.
So we would encourage you to
have Slido up on your phone
with the event
code, Rkeynote,
and we're going to be using
some polls during this talk to,
for us in this
room and people who
are watching from afar
to be able to share
their own experiences,
opinions and perspectives.
So, what we're going to
be talking about today
is the software that we
build for machine learning,
and that is tidymodels.
So you can think of tidymodels
as a meta package that
helps you install and
manage other packages that
are used for modeling
and machine learning in
R, these packages
work together,
but each have a
specific focus.
It works much the same way
that the tidyverse does.
So if you have ever
typed library tidyverse
and then used ggplot2 for
data visualization, dplyr
for data manipulation, you
can think about tidymodels
as working in the same way
you type library tidymodels,
and then you have access to
these different packages that
have a focused purpose.
So yardstick, for
example, is a package
that is used to measure model
performance. Tune, perhaps
unsurprisingly, is a package
for hyperparameter tuning.
So this is a great way to
think about tidymodels
that it's an R package
that gives you access
to all these kinds of
functions that work together.
It's also right to be
thinking about tidymodels
as a unified
framework for modeling
in R. The ecosystem
for modeling
in R is one of
our big strengths.
It is a reason why people choose
to use R. At the same time it
really presents a challenge
because the interface to all
these different kinds of
models are very heterogeneous.
If you have set up
a model analysis
using one kind of
model, the moving
over to a different
type of model
often involves starting
over from scratch
with your whole approach.
Tidymodels provides
a unified interface
to a vast array of modeling
approaches, feature engineering
approaches, and encourages
good statistical practice
via its design.
Now some of you are sitting
out there and you're thinking,
wait a minute, R already
has several of these.
In fact, that person
standing there
next to Julia
talking right now is
one of the people who
has built one already.
So, Max, what's going on?
Why yet another modeling
framework for R? Why
would Max do this,
right?
So I wrote a package a
while back called caret,
and it's another similar
modeling framework.
And it was in 2005,
which many of you know,
if you develop packages back
then, we're a different time.
There were no namespaces
in R, for example,
and it was lacking a lot of
the things that we have now.
I was also kind of doing
it in my spare time,
and it wasn't really
engineered in a way
that we could sort
of port it over
to new and better interfaces
and extend it really well.
So, you know, learning more
as I've gone on about software
engineering, I think if I'd
known those things back then,
I would have done some things
different under the hood.
So it's not really
something that
is really extendable
at this point.
But maybe more
importantly, it's really
not something that has,
it's not a bad interface,
but it's a very
2005 interface where
you have one function that
does just about everything
and has like 30 options to it.
So we were thinking about doing
more and more with caret.
It would be really
difficult because if we
add more types of sampling or
more pre processors or this
or that, then you
have a function that
has like maybe 100
or so options, which
is not a good design.
And so since 2005,
I think we've really
learned a lot more about
how to write a good R package,
but we've learned a lot more
about how people interact
with our software a lot more.
And then, you know,
as time goes on,
you see things that are
happening in ggplot
even just plyr and then dplyr,
and things like that.
So I think we've learned
like as a community,
a lot more about what are good
ways of writing interfaces
to packages.
And then as I started
to think about that,
I think about this in
the context of modeling
and it seemed really
like it would make sense
to have more of like a tidy
modern interface to modeling.
And so that's really the reason
to build a whole new sort
of stack from the beginning,
from the bottom up,
because really what was
old wasn't engineered
well enough to extend.
And also just its whole,
its whole view of the world
was not really very modern.
So that's why we're going
to do something different.
So a lot of times we want to
introduce software and talk
about, let's say, our
philosophy and why we do things.
A lot of times we want
to start off with a data
set that we can use
to illustrate things.
So here's the data set that
some of you have seen
it's Spotify data.
So each row in the data
frame is a track or a song.
We might want to do
some modeling on this.
This was in a Sliced competition.
The outcome is the popularity
column right there.
That's a numeric.
So we want to try
to predict that
with the other columns
that are in this data set.
Other interesting features,
there's an artist feature
and as you might imagine,
there are quite a large number
of artists in the
Spotify catalog.
So we might think about
ways we could deal with that
when we go to do modeling.
There's a date field
and we might not
want to put date
directly into a model.
We might be better off by
deriving features from it,
like an indicator for month
or year or any seasonality
or any sort of
date-based features
instead of using the
original date value.
And then we sort of
have this monster
of a column over
here, this character,
and it's really like a
multiple choice type field,
sort in a delimited format.
And what we'd like
to do is we think
that maybe genres are
probably important to predict
popularity.
So we'd have to deal
with this data somehow.
We'd have to find all the
genres that are in the data.
Figure out how to encode
them into our model
matrix or the data we hand
off to the model in a way
that we could make that work.
And so there's this
sort of idea that we
have of like what our modeling
script is going to look like.
And we read books
and we see websites
and blogs and things like that.
I think we're always led
to believe that there's
this perfect data set that
were handed by our associates
and there's a single call
to a modeling function.
It's really clean and
nice, and then you're
going to make predictions and
it's just like a single line
and you're fine.
It's no big deal.
But the reality
is more like this.
It's like a
Franken-script.
So, you know, back when
I used to do modeling,
I had a lot of scripts that I
like to handle multiple choice
values that I'd use
across different projects
and then different jobs
and things like that.
So I think this is
more the reality
of how most of our
modeling scripts look like.
And a lot of this is about
the data preprocessing.
So, you know, at the
top there like,
we might use something like
a technique called effect
encoding to handle the
large number of artists that
require some
statistical estimation
of the effect of each artist.
You might do things convert
your, you know, all of us
have lubridate commands, right?
That use like
wday and all that
to make date features that
we then put in our model.
There's code there to parse
the multiple choice field
and then at some point, we
have way too many features.
So we might think about
doing some feature selection.
And so there's this
big scripts that we
have to do before we get
to that actual line, one
line of modeling.
So this is the
reality of things.
And it's not great.
I mean, it's not something
if you do this for a living,
you want to have to
deal with every time you
get a new data set.
Now we'll come
back to that slide
and we'll also come back to
this slide couple of times.
And the point we want
to make with this slide
is that we're doing even
before we get to the model,
we're doing a lot of estimation
and a lot of quasi-modeling
work.
So there are things
here that we're
estimating from a
statistical standpoint
and also to say that when
we go to predict new data,
we have to apply all those
same transformations to data
we might get six months from
now to make a prediction.
So a good chunk of that,
that sort of script
on the last slide has to carry
over to your other prediction
script and you have
to keep using it.
So it's a bit of a mess.
And that's somebody who
did this for a living.
Like this is a great
problem to solve,
and I think it's
probably pretty solvable.
I really love this
visualization of what
you think your script
is going to look like.
And how it actually
ends up turning out
aligns so much with my
practical experience.
And that's why we
want to talk to you
here about why tidymodels
is designed the way it is
and how it can support
more ergonomic approaches
to modeling.
By ergonomic, what
we mean here, this
is really about syntax,
about how expressive
you can be in the code that you
write, how fluent you are in,
and how, how, how the
syntax that you write
helps you get your work done.
We also want to talk
about how tidymodels will
make you more effective.
What we mean by
effective here is
that it allows you as
a practical modeling
practitioner, to have access to
a wide swath of different kinds
of approaches. That
it enables you to do
many different kinds of things.
And last, we want to
talk to you about how
tidymodels keeps you safe.
The process of machine learning
has many pitfalls or potholes
in the road on the
way, if you will,
and what tidy, tidymodels is designed
to help you avoid those
pitfalls, those potholes.
So, Max, let's
start with talking
about being more ergonomic.
What, how do you think
how do you think
about being ergonomic
when it comes to modeling?
So a lot of times I think
about physical ergonomics.
Like when I worked
in diagnostics, we
have people come
in with clinicians
and they would interact
with the diagnostic machines
we had and we'd
watch them and see
like just as they did their
work, like what were things
they did over and over again or
they might get frustrated with.
And there's a lot of that in
the syntax, the way we design
syntax for our functions, but in
particular to machine learning,
there's an extra layer of things
that we have to think about,
because there's a high amount
of cognitive load for machine
learning.
So when you go to do a
model for the first time,
or if you're, let's
say, taking a workshop
to learn about machine
learning before you can even
get to your first model fit.
There's all this stuff that
we have to throw at you.
We have to talk about
overfitting in data splitting
and training and test sets,
and there's a lot of jargon
and a lot of things.
It's like, you do this and
then this and then this,
and then, you know, a day
or two later or maybe you're
fitting your first model.
And so what we want
to do is we want
to simplify this process,
maybe in ways you don't even
see in terms of the syntax.
So we want to take
this complexity
and reduce it down a little bit.
We don't want to stop you from doing
really sophisticated things.
And having access to the
functions and the nitty
gritty bits.
But we do want to give
you really good APIs
that for like 80% of
the work, the syntax
should be pretty high level
and consumable by just
about anybody.
So one aspect of
machine learning
and really complicated
or sophisticated
statistical models is, we have
to think about what our data are
and how we're going to use them.
So we're going to do
our first Slido poll.
So go ahead to slido.com
if you haven't already.
And the key or the event
code is Rkeynote.
And so what we
want to talk about
is the types of
roles you would have
when you're building models.
And so this is multiple choice.
So like A and B are the
things that we probably
think about normally,
predictors and outcomes.
But, you know, there are
more sophisticated methods
you might use with case
weights, like frequency weights,
or importance weights,
or survey weights.
In some cases, you
might be modeling
and you have
stratification variables.
Have you ever used those? Things
like censoring indicators?
So Hannah Frick will be talking
about our code or our package
for survival analysis.
If you've ever used that,
like choose this on the quiz.
And then there's some
old school things
like offsets for Poisson
data and things like that.
So the point is
like we're normally
thinking about things in
a pretty simplistic way,
but once we get more
and more sophisticated
and the types of models
that we want to fit
and the types of
problems that we have,
it actually gets more complex.
And we want to make sure
that complexity for you
doesn't get overwhelming as
we work with tidy models.
So let's look at
recipes for a minute,
so we'll use that as an example.
So what recipes are are a kind
of a combination of the R formula
method that you see
in modeling functions
sort of combined with like
a dplyr sort of approach
where you're going to be
basically piping in operations
that you want to do to your data
before you get it to the model.
So in the first line
there, we learned
that we load the tidymodels package, which
again loads the
core tidymodels packages
plus some tidyverse packages.
And when you start
modeling, a lot
of things that we
typically do is
we do an initial
split of our data
into testing and training set.
So that second line is just
taking our data set that's
in a Spotify data frame
and then converting
that to an object that has
all the indicators for row 7
goes in training, row 10
goes in testing and so on.
And so when you want to
access the training set,
if you look at the right
hand side of the third line,
you'll see that we can
run a function called
training on that
split object and that
will return the data frame that
corresponds to the training
set.
So in that first line,
what we're doing is
we're starting a recipe and
there's a formula method there.
It says popularity tilde dot.
The left hand side says
popularity is an outcome.
That's its role in the analysis.
And the dot means
everything else
that's in that data
frame besides popularity
should be, by default, considered to be a predictor.
Now you can have a lot of
different roles in recipes.
You can make up roles
for whatever you want.
But right now, at this
point, all the recipe
does is it sort of
catalogs the data.
What's in the dataframe,
is it numeric?
Is it date is a
categorical that sort
of thing, and then it
assigns it like a basic role
for the analysis.
So what we can do then is
as we want to do operations
on our data to prepare
it for modeling,
we can sort of
pipe in new steps,
new functions that
represent data processing
steps in our recipe.
So let's say we're going to use
a model like a neural network
or nearest neighbor
model where we
have to make sure that
our predictors are
all in the same units.
And one common way of doing
that is centering and scaling
your data.
So a step function we have for
that is called step normalize.
And after step
normalize, you can
use any sort of dplyr selectors
like you would in the dplyr
select function to say which
variable should be affected
by this can use contains
and starts with,
or you can just list the
actual variables like unquoted.
But we know from the
modeling standpoint,
when we make choices
about these things,
we're thinking about what
type of role the variable is
and what its type is.
You wouldn't go and
try to center and scale
like categorical data.
So what we've done is
we've given recipes
a lot of extra dplyr
selectors to let
you choose the model
related context in which you
want to use variables.
So you see that all
nominal or I'm sorry,
all numeric predictors
and it's doing
what you think. It's
going to select anything
at that point that exists in
the recipe that is numeric
and has a role of predictor.
So when we think about
the complexity of how
we work with and
handle data, we're
adding a lot of
bells and whistles
that are like quite literal that
will make your use of recipes
and more complicated
functions go a lot easier.
So when we go back to our what
I keep calling the Franken
script, you know, we
have all these things
that we wanted to do our data
before we give it to the model.
And it's and it's kind of, like
I said, a big mess of scripts.
You know, parts of these
scripts are probably
never been like unit tested
and things like that.
It's this stuff that you've
had along for the ride
for a few years, and so we can
convert that into a recipe.
So in that yellow box
you see a series of steps
and they do all the things
that we talked about doing.
You might use the step date
to take the date field that's
in there and convert that to
new features for date and year
and things like that.
The step after that is
the step that we have that
is good for parsing multiple
choice columns that are text.
So we get all the genres, make
all the indicator variables
for them, which is quite a lot.
But at the end of
that you might think
you have too many variables
to put in your model,
so you might want to do some
sort of unsupervised feature
filter to get rid of
redundant predictors.
You might have two genres that
kind of do the same thing.
They're almost identical.
And so the step
below that step core
is one that can actually
remove predictors in case
their collinearity
or their their.
pairwise correlations
are too high.
So all these things you can
put into a single object,
you can save that object,
you can carry it around.
It's not in a bunch of scripts.
It's been unit tested and it
has a lot of features in it.
So we want to simplify
that part of the process.
So the last three lines
in the yellow block,
we do something like we create
what's called a workflow
object, and that's
a situation where
you want to take a complicated
preprocessor like a recipe
and bind it together to
whatever type of model
that you want to use.
And in this case, we're going
to use a machine learning
model called cubist.
It's a very sophisticated
rule based model.
So in that workflow call,
I'm binding together
my data processing
recipe, and I'm saying,
we're going to use
this with cubist.
And then there's a simple fit
function we use after that.
And that does all
the preprocessing,
all the estimation that
happens during preprocessing
for this recipe hands
the data off to cubist.
It runs all its model and
it's all sitting in one object
that you can save or
deploy, spoiler alert,
and do your things with.
And so that last blue block
is that one line for predict
that we'd like to be able to do.
And it does all the same
things for your new data.
So we want to try to
simplify this process
as much as possible.
I mean, that recipe is
not terribly simple,
but it's also a very like,
predictable,
tested, reliable way
to encapsulate
your preprocessing.
So when we think
about ergonomics,
that's the kind of thing
we're talking about.
We want to do potentially very
simple or potentially very
sophisticated things
with a really nice API
that we think you'll
enjoy working with.
However, there may be parts
of the modeling development
process that maybe
aren't so ergonomic.
Anything you would like
to mention about that, Julia?
Yeah, in my
experience and talking
with folks about
their modeling, one
of the parts of the whole
modeling analysis that
has been the least ergonomic
that has involved the most pain
is the process of getting
your model off your machine.
You know, you would
spend time training,
tuning, developing a beautiful,
accurate, appropriate model.
And then when it's time
to deploy that model,
to put that model
into production,
there has been a
real lack of tools
for people who are
excellent model
developers to be able to take
that model and get it off
where it needs to go.
Let's let's do another
poll here together.
And let's take this time to
reflect a little bit on what
your experience has been like.
If you if you have deployed
a model to production,
think about what has
been what has gone well,
what has been what have
been the pain points,
whether that's the
code that you needed
to write that was awkward, or
the collaboration between you
and the software engineers or
IT folks in your organization.
If you haven't deployed
a model to production,
reflect on why that is.
Is that because it really
isn't part of your job
like you don't need to
in your organization?
Or is it because there
have been barriers?
There are - you -  maybe
you didn't know how
or maybe it was
difficult to collaborate
within your organization
to get your model where
it needs to go.
Maybe some of you are sitting
here and you're like, what?
What does that even mean
for the word production?
That's a great
question because there
isn't some industry
standard definition
for what production means.
I like to use the
definition or the idea
that putting a model
into production
is taking your trained
model, getting it
out of the computational
environment where
you trained it and
putting it somewhere where
it is useful to a
wider group of people.
So by that definition,
taking a model
and putting it in a Shiny
app and letting people
interact to get
predictions, you know,
we can say that's production.
The industry standard these
days for model putting models
into production for
model deployment
is to create RESTful APIs so
that you can scale your API,
you can have it
as a microservice.
And we have this convenient way
to take a model that you have
trained and put it in a
computational environment
where it's accessible to
anyone in your organization
who needs it.
I've been working on a new
framework for model deployment
and other ML ops
tasks called vetiver.
So if you are into perfumery
or fancy candles like I am,
you may have seen this
word, this word vetiver.
So vetiver is a stabilizing
ingredient in perfume.
It takes, the more
volatile fragrances
and it stabilizes them.
So in this metaphor, your model
is this more volatile thing.
You have used
different hyperparameters,
you have used different
data, and vetiver
helps you stabilize it
so you can version it,
deploy it and monitor it.
Let's walk through
that a little briefly.
So any modeling
process starts with you
collecting data, having
access to some kind of data.
The first thing you need to
do is to understand, clean,
you need to engage in the
process of exploratory data
analysis.
There are great tools
in Python and R
for you to approach those tasks.
Next, you want to
train your model,
you want to train,
tune, evaluate.
And again, there are
amazing open source tools
like what we are talking
about to be able to approach
those kinds of tasks.
So far, at this point,
that becomes less true
as we move around this cycle.
Once your model is
trained, you need
to have a reliable scheme to
version that model so that you
can know which version of my
model was used over which time
with each data, once
your model is versioned,
you need to deploy it.
And after it's
deployed, your job
is not done.
You need to also
monitor your model.
You need to measure
regularly the statistical,
the statistical characteristics
of how your model is performing
so that you can make
adjustments, decide to retrain,
head down that path.
So the tasks on the right
side of this diagram
are ones that there are
great open source tools for.
The task on the
left side are ones
where that has not been true and
this is where vetiver sits - So,
Vetiver is a framework
for versioning, deploying
and monitoring your model.
Now you can probably
guess from this slide
that vetiver is not
just for tidymodels,
it supports many
kinds of models in R,
and Vetiver is not just for R.
Vetiver was designed
from the beginning
to have feature parity
between R and Python.
You can use the
tools that you want
to use to understand and clean
your data to train your model.
And then Vetiver can
support these ML ops tasks
for both Python and R.
If you want to learn
more about what MLOps is
and how Vetiver works with
a specifically with a Python
flavor, I invite you to come
to the talk of my coworker
Isabel Zimmerman, which is in
the next session about MLOps
and Vetiver.
While you're here
though, I'll just
show you what this looks
like in R a little bit.
So let's say I, I trained that
model that Max talked about
and now it's time to deploy it.
The first step is to create
a deployable model object.
This collects all
the information
that we need to be able to
move this model from where
I trained it over to a new
computational environment
where I can make predictions.
This information includes
the types and number
and names of the predictors,
the original predictors.
This includes also the
packages and package versions,
the specific software
that is needed
to be installed over
in that other place
to be able to make predictions.
Once we have that
deployable model object,
the process of spinning up
an API is quite ergonomic.
This was our goal here.
So on the R side, we
use the Plumber package
and once you have a
Plumber router initialized,
it is literally just
one line of code
to spin up your model
aware API that's
ready to make, to serve
predictions at an endpoint.
So this is what we
mean by ergonomic.
We want to let
you be expressive,
to let you be fluent, to
let you get your job done
in this way.
Now, let's move on
to our second point,
which is how tidymodels
makes you more effective.
Max, what when we think about
this like being effective,
what are some of the things
that come to mind for you?
So, you know, back when I used
to do modeling for a living,
I feel like I was most
effective when somebody
brought some data to me.
Like to know of like a new project
and I was able to give them
a predictive model back that
really like met or exceeded
what they were interested in
or what they needed for
the problem and not take,
let's say, like months
to be able to do that.
So for me, effective is
being able to produce
a performant model for
whatever the context is
or whatever the requirements
are for the project
and do that pretty efficiently.
So, you know, what
we'll talk about in
a minute are some
sort of advanced tools
that we can give
you to help do that.
Some are about performance,
some are about efficiency.
A big part of building
a machine learning model
is model tuning, which
we mentioned earlier,
where you have these
hyperparameters that you can't
directly estimate from
the data and you need
to find a way to tune them.
So another poll here.
Have you ever tuned a model?
So, for example, if you
have a neural network.
And you want to figure
out how many hidden units
or hidden layers
you should have,
you need to do some sort of
methodology to figure out what
a good, what good values are
for those tuning parameters.
So have you never done that?
Yes and I don't want to
ever do that again situation.
Maybe you did it in a worked
well or you do it all the time
and it was easy, or you're
a pro, so we definitely
want to get feedback from you.
We don't get the feedback
from the Slido polls
as we do them.
But honestly, for
this in the next one,
I'm kind of dying to see
what your responses are.
So go ahead and let us know
what you think about that.
So just as an example
of some techniques
to talk about
effectiveness, you know,
there's a lot of things that
aren't like bleeding edge,
but they're relatively
cutting edge
and might be coming from
different parts of literature.
Some things we
include in tiny models
are from the deep
learning literature.
There's actually some
interesting things
we're doing from the
computational chemistry
literature that we're using
for other types of data
or any type of data.
Some examples of that would
be feature embedding methods,
and these are just really
fancy machine learning methods
for dimensionality reduction.
So UMAP and isoMap, like
multidimensional scaling
are pretty powerful and
interesting methods,
and we'd like you to be able
to use them for any data
and use them with any model.
So we want to enable you
to use those pretty easily.
The effect encoding is
the type of methodology
might use, like with the artist
field and the Spotify data
where you have a large
number of values,
you need to find an
efficient and practical way
of doing that.
You know, that's not a
terribly sophisticated method,
but if you were
doing that before,
you would have had to write
a bunch of other stuff
in your script to do that
before and after modeling.
And we'll talk about model
tuning just a little bit more.
Bayesian optimization is a tool
that's pretty, pretty common
in the deep learning
or neural network side,
but you can use
that for anything.
There are a few packages
in order to do that,
but they're not really
well integrated overall
with all the types of models.
We provide you tuning methods
for Bayesian optimization you
could use for your boosted tree
or for support vector machine
or whatever you're going to do.
And then racing is
an example we'll look
at in a little bit more detail.
It's a way to do really,
really efficient grid search.
So in grid search you might
come up with for your tuning
parameters, you might
come up with a number
of different candidate
like values of their tuning
parameters.
So you might say,
let's try seven hidden
units and 12 hidden
units and two
and so on, but you
pre-define them.
And the problem with
grid search sometimes
is you don't know if some
of those choices you made
about the candidate parameters
are any good until you're
done with all the computations.
And so what racing does is it's
a dynamic way of doing that,
is as you start to
do the model tuning,
it's starting to
look at the results
as they happen and look at some
tuning parameter combinations
and say, oh, those are
never going to be the best.
So it does some
statistics to like estimate
the probability that something
will be the winner in this race
and it lets you do
things very efficiently.
So in this little
animation we have here,
the y-axis is 50 different
model configurations
for a machine learning
model, and the x-axis
is a measurement of performance.
And so the blue dot, if you
can see it there, near the top,
is the current winner
during each re resample
that we're doing
for our grid search.
And as you can see, a lot
of these candidate values
got grayed out and were
eliminated on the next step.
So every time it
does a resample,
it's doing some analysis
to figure out what's good
and what's bad and it
gets rid of the bad stuff.
And so really quickly after
like eight or 10 resamples,
you're down to just a
handful of models out of 50.
And in this particular
case, of all the models
you could have fit,
you would be actually
only fitting about 7% of them.
And if you're working
with parallel processing,
that's like almost like
a three-fold increase
in efficiency.
So it took you a third
of the time it would have
done with regular grid search.
And if you weren't using
parallel processing,
it's a nine times as fast
as what you could have
done with regular grid search.
So these are
examples of the types
of things that we want
to implement, like
we're giving you APIs for
them that are pretty simple,
let you control a lot of
things, but will make it easier
for you to go further and
faster with your modeling.
This racing example
is such a great one
because it really highlights
how tidymodels is extensible.
The package that provides that
infrastructure is not a core
tidymodels package,
but an extension package.
So the metaphor that we can
think about here together
is one of LEGOs.
So if you have one
beautiful LEGO block here,
we can admire it.
Look, look how
well it's designed.
But the reason why LEGOs
are fun to play with
is that you can
put them together
and you can put them together
in the way that meets your needs
or fulfills your vision, or is
what it is that you want to -
what is what you want to build.
And that is how tidymodels works.
We showed a, you
know, a handful
of hex stickers up before that
were some core tidymodels
packages, but -
and said, you know,
this is tidymodels,
but if we ask the question,
what else is tidymodels?
There's another whole
group of packages that
are for our more specialized tasks.
I'm just going to run
through the ones on the top
there briefly.
Text recipes is a feature
engineering extension package
for text preprocessing
text feature engineering.
This is one of my favorite
things to talk about.
And tidymodels
gives you great tools
to make you effective
in building text models.
The next one there is
the censored package,
which is for survival analysis.
Our coworker Hannah is
going to be giving a talk
on that in the next session,
if you particularly work
with survival analysis.
The next one is
interesting, stacks,
because it builds on top of
the whole tidymodels framework
to actually to take multiple
different kinds of models
and stack them together
or ensemble them
so that you can squeeze
that last bit of performance
out of your data that you have
if that's something
that is important
in your particular use case.
The last one up
there is modeltime.
And I want to highlight
this because this one is
a package that's not
built by us who work
on the tidymodels team.
It's actually built by a
member of our community.
So this is built by Matt Dancho,
who is here somewhere today
and it highlights how
tidymodels is extensible,
not just by us but also by you.
This is true whether you're
interested in building
some open source software
for a new kind of model
or a new kind of resampling.
It's also true, just within
your own organization,
you can build, for
example, a custom metric
based on your
company's KPIs and use
that to optimize the models
that you are training.
Now, when we start talking
about all these packages,
one of the things that we
start to hear from people
is a bit of discomfort
with the fact
that there are so many packages.
How do I know which
one does what?
How do I find them?
And we want to acknowledge
that, that yeah, there,
there is this little bit
of a learning process.
And it's important to have
tools in your, in your tool belt
to be able to identify
what functions
come from what packages.
However, we really want to
emphasize that this modularity
makes all of our lives better.
It makes our lives better as
maintainers of the packages,
and it makes your lives better
as users of the package.
Smaller, more
modular packages can
be released more frequently.
With smaller changes, we
can more quickly fix bugs,
so it makes our lives
quite a bit better.
It makes your lives
better directly,
not only because we're doing
a better job maintaining,
but actually directly.
And this is, I would
say, most highlighted
when we are talking
about model deployment.
Let's say we train the
model using that racing
method that Max shared with us.
We don't need any of that
racing infrastructure when
we go to deploy our model.
In fact, we don't need the
tuning infrastructure at all.
We need a subset of
the modeling software
that is required to
make a prediction.
Our packages being
modular, allows
you to make smaller
docker images,
have far faster
installation times,
being able to have more
scalable models in production.
So, so far we've
talked about how we
can have a more ergonomic
modeling process.
We have talked about
how we can make
you more effective in the
models that you build.
And last, we want to
talk about being safe,
practicing safe
machine learning.
So, Max, how does tidymodels
keep us safe?
So the whole idea of
safety in modeling, you
might be like, well, what do you
mean by safety or being safe?
It turns out with like complex
machine learning models
and especially complex
data, it's possible for you
to do something
horribly wrong and not
really know it until a
really inopportune time.
And I've made this
confession several times
at different conferences
and things like that.
But, you know, in
my first job, I
had a project that was like
3/4 of the total R&D budget.
You know, we were doing a
bunch of sophisticated machine
learning with like a large
number of predictors,
and we thought we'd
gotten it to a good point.
And my boss came by and
he said, how's it look?
And I'm like, accuracy is like,
like 90%. It's like, great.
And, and then we
got more samples in
and we missed them all.
And we did a lot of soul
searching in the days
after that and figured out
some methodology mistakes
that we made that others make,
just to be honest with you
quite often.
And once we figure that out
and fixed it, we, we had more
genuine estimates performance.
So there are times in
modeling where, especially
if you're doing
something complex,
that you might
accidentally fool yourself
into believing you have
something that's really good,
but you have something
that's actually not as good,
and you won't figure that
out until we get new data.
And here's one of the
reasons is going back
to this part of
our previous slides
is we have all
the modeling parts
and those are pretty well
understood, how to validate them
and how to assess them.
But very often before
we get to the model,
we might do something
either simple or something
really complex to the data
that involves something
that's not like a deterministic,
like data cleaning operation.
We might be doing some
statistical estimation, right?
So remember you're
talking about the effect
encoding or measuring
the redundancies
between predictors.
And so it's really, really
important in some cases
that we handle that
in the right way
to make sure that our
statistics that tell us
how well our model
is doing, take
into account the good and
bad parts that might happen
in that part of the system.
So let's think about
our Spotify script.
We have all these genres,
maybe we got rid of redundancy,
but maybe we want to refine that
feature set a little bit more
before we give it to our model.
And let's say we want to do
some fancy supervised feature
selection routine.
So we might want to pick
the top 10 variables
to give to the model and
pick those 10 because they're
the most influential
for the outcome,
like for popularity
in this case.
So that's like a feature, a
supervised feature selection
technique.
And so let's say in
our Spotify data,
we're going to do
10-fold cross validation
to validate our model and we're
going to use feature selection.
So actually, how
many times do you
think we're going to run
that feature selection or are
we going to run it once?
Are we going to run it 10 times?
We could run it 11
times or we could
run it some fractional
amount of time
because it was taking so
long that you just like hash.
You know, you slam
the Escape key
until it stopped after
three iterations.
I want to see the results
of these later on today.
And it's not like
a trick question,
but there's actually
more than one of these
could be true.
And I'll talk about
that in a second.
So here's the situation
we're in is we have some data,
we have a list of predictors.
We want to enact some
sort of feature selection
routine to filter out
some of those predictors
before we give it to our model.
Let's just say for kicks we're
doing ordinary least squares
with lm.
And so that produces some
sort of fitted model.
And that red box
there is basically
the box that says like,
what am I estimating
and what should I validate here
in the way we have the diagram
here treats the
feature selection bit
as if it were sort
of outside the model.
So if I were to ask
most people like where
are we modeling in this
diagram, they would probably
do what we show and just circle
the actual technical model
part of the process.
But in actuality, what you have
to do is you have to do this.
And in this previous
slide, this is
what I did when I made that
horrible mistake in my job
is I just selected the features
once, put them into the model,
and there's a big sort
of circular argument
methodology wise in
doing that and it gave me
really bad results.
What we want to do is this.
So the answer to
this is probably
C where for every one of
those 10-fold cross validations,
you do the feature selection
over and over again.
And that may seem like excessive
or it may take a long time,
but at the same time, you can't
measure the effect of something
that's not within your
sort of validation system.
If it's outside of it, it
might give you bad answers.
So the answer is
probably B, which is 10.
But let's say this model
was really, really good
and you liked it.
And compared to all the
other things that you did,
this is the one you want
to take to production.
You want to put it in
Vetiver and deploy it.
Well, actually, what
you would end up
doing is doing it in 11
time, because to build
the final model, you have
to do the feature section
on the entire data set
hand that data over to lm
and run lm on the
entire data set.
So really the answer
there is either B or C,
but it's highlighting that there
are some pitfalls and gotchas.
That is really easy
for somebody like me
who studied this
in graduate school
and did it for a
living for a while,
that you could actually
make these mistakes.
Unfortunately, it
happens quite a bit.
So, you know, there's quite a
few papers that talk about this
and measure this, but there's
one that just came out,
you know, we're bringing it
up because their findings were
maybe like not great.
So leakage in this
context is data leakage.
And it's really where
you're using the wrong data.
It may be the wrong time to
do some sort of calculation.
Right so in my case, I was
doing feature selection
at the wrong time
with data that maybe I
shouldn't have been using.
And so in this paper,
what they do is
they look at a lot of
different publications.
And you can tell
based on their method
sections what they were doing.
And there was a lot of
situations where they're
doing like the bad methodology.
And in tidymodels,
what we want to do
is whether people
know it or not is
we sort of want to silently
sort of give you guardrails.
So if you follow the
process of tidy models
and use a tiny model syntax,
it's very, very, very difficult
to do the wrong thing.
So just to give you an example
of that, here's another recipe.
We're going to use a recipe
extension package written
by somebody in the community
called recipe selectors,
and that has a recipe
in it that will do like,
let's say like a random forest
variable importance score
across your predictors.
And then you can select the
top 10 or 15 or 30, whatever
you want you to think you
should do of the most predictors
and give that to, let's say,
your, your linear regression
model, but we don't really
know how many we should pick.
So if you look at
that line there, it
has an argument called
tune or I'm sorry, top_p
So it's like how many predictors
should I retain?
We give that a value of
tune and that value of tune
marks it in tidy models
as being something
that we want to optimize.
We want to tune that parameter.
And so then we can take
our new recipe that
built on our previous Spotify
recipe, put that in a workflow
with a modeling
function that says
we're going to use just
plain old linear regression,
and we could use the
tune grid function
to do a grid search to find
a good value for how many
of those predictors
that we should use.
And so this is how you
would do the feature
selection in tidymodels.
Now the thing is, the way
we've set up sampling and data
splitting, the way
we're combining our pre
processor with our model,
it's nearly impossible
if you accidentally do the wrong
thing here and inappropriately
validate or estimate
things from your data.
So we're really,
without really saying
that, we're sort of forcing
that methodology for users.
That idea of making it
hard to do the wrong thing
leads us to wanting to talk
about one more metaphor here.
When we're here talking
about being on the road,
being on this journey
as we drive down,
this may not be 100%
resonant to those of you
who are visiting here from
outside the United States,
maybe where you
live, somewhere where
you have excellent
public transportation.
But I have always
lived somewhere
where I rely on a car, like I
rely on a car to get around.
And the idea of locking
my keys in my car
is something that is kind of
terrifying because it's like,
oh, no, what do I do now?
I'm stuck somewhere.
So here together, let's,
let's answer another poll.
So when was the
last time that you
locked your keys in your car?
Was it pretty recently?
Was it a long time ago.
Have you have you
never done this?
Max, when was the last time you
locked your keys in your car?
I would pick D
about 10 years ago.
Yeah, I would pick D too.
It was like 10 or 15 years
ago was the last time
that I locked my keys in my car
and I wouldn't be surprised.
I have a bunch of people here
choose that they have never
locked their keys in their
car, and I don't think
it's because that much more
responsible or good at handling
keys than we are,
but rather that
you're quite a bit younger
than Max and I are.
Because the thing is,
the car that I have now,
it's really hard to
lock my keys in my car.
Now, the car itself
is built in such a way
that it protects against
common failure modes.
So this I - this is how
tidymodels is built.
It is built to protect you
against these common pitfalls,
potholes that are on your road
to developing and deploying
your model.
So the idea of keys is like
an immediately painful problem
and that some problems that you
run into in machine learning
are like that. One I
might suggest here
would be the model deployment.
You know, you're like,
oh, it's, I can't get it.
It fails every time I try to
push it to wherever I'm going.
There are other kinds of
problems, though, that
are not obvious until later.
So the metaphor
we might use here
would be not filling
your car up with gas
and just driving along.
And because you didn't
make that choice
at the last exit
that had gas, you
end up running out of gas later.
tidymodels also protects
you against problems
like that.  That you make some decision
during your modeling process.
And it may not come to
bite you until you're
predicting on new data.
So as we come up and
start to wrap up here,
we want to share a thought
from my friend and co-author
Dave Robinson, who started
using tidymodels about a year ago
and wrote a blog post
reflecting on his experience.
So he said that, you know,
he, like us, sometimes
hears some resistance
to the idea of
or how tidy models works
that it makes it too easy.
You know, people
you're not really
thinking about what it
is that you're doing.
But like, Dave, we think
this is entirely backwards.
This is entirely backwards.
We want to protect you as
a modeling practitioner
from making silent
but bad choices so
that you don't have to worry
and stress about those things.
And you can focus on the
scientific and statistical
questions that are the
reason why you're training
a model in the first place.
So, Max, here we are.
What does this mean?
Well, I think it means that
we're at the point with tidymodels where
it's mature enough.
The syntax is pretty much solid.
No super major
changes we're going
to be doing any minute now
that would affect users.
You may have noticed the
flurry of CRAN submissions
where we've revved
everything to 1.0.
So I think the message we
want to get across to you
is it's ready for
your day to day work.
Like if I were working
in my previous job,
I would be using this, you
know, to finish projects and do
things on time.
You know, it's at that
point where we really
feel confident that you can use
it and depend on it in your day
to day work.
Now that doesn't
mean things like,
yeah, the unit test
pass, we're good,
or it passes R command
check or something like that.
We want to build a good system.
We want you to be
able to use it.
We want to make sure
it works, but we also
want you to learn it if
you've never seen it before.
We don't just want to be like,
you know, read the man page.
So at the very beginning of
the pandemic, what we did
was spent a lot of
time, really writing
a lot of good documentation.
So tinymodels.org is a website
that has some really
good content on it.
You can see there's a section
there for getting started.
There's a great
sequence of articles
that will introduce you to
tinymodels, show you how to use it.
There's a lot of
articles about if you
want to have an example
of Bayesian optimization
or bootstrapping to compute
confidence intervals
and things like that, that's
all on tidymodels.org.
There's quite a lot
of content there.
In addition to that, you may
have seen the other night
that Julia and I finished
writing a book on tidymodels
from O'Reilly.
They should be
printing them now.
Hopefully we'll get copies
in the next week or two.
The website's down
there, if you want
to look at the bookdown version.
So, so check that out.
It's a really good way, if you
like, longer form documentation
to learn about tidymodels.
So we think it's not
only ready for you,
but we think we have lots and
lots of good materials publicly
available for you to learn
it and interact with it.
So I think the last things
we want to say are Thank you.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you,
if you're in the room,
thank you if you're remote.
We appreciate you coming.
We also want to thank
our teams, so we
want to Thank the rest of the
tidymodels team Simon, Hannah,
Emil and Davis, the
Vetiver team's excellent,
Michael and Isabel.
It's great having people
from a Python background.
It's really like,
enriching our
perspectives on how
we do things in modeling
and deployment in general.
And then there's a
lot of other people
that have had a really,
really big impact on our work,
whether it's through like
helping us design software
or giving us feedback or helping
us make training materials.
So we have a great, great team
inside of Posit and outside of Posit.
See what I just did?
The thing we really
want to do also
is to really, really thank all
the people who've contributed
since this started in 2017.
So we just want to call them
out in our own special way.
We don't have to wait for that.
So thank you for coming.
Thank you.
Thanks, Max.
Thanks, Julia.
We've now got time
for some questions.
And remember, go to Slido if
you want to ask your questions.
I do not see any
questions there yet.
So I will make chit chat
with Julia and Max until...
OK, we're getting some
questions rolling in,
I'll still make a little.
A little chit chat.
One one thing I forgot
to mention in my intro
is that Max and Julia
have a book "tidy modeling
with R" coming out
very soon with O'Reilly.
Unfortunately, not in time to
make it for this conference,
but it should be out in
the very near future.
Yes and of course, you can
read it online for free.
Yeah do you have any, like
iTunes albums coming out
from our SoundCloud?
Our SoundCloud.
We'll just drop our SoundCloud.
It's just yelling
at our keyboards
while we do programming.
Right OK.
So first question,
are you planning
to integrate tidymodels
with other data
structures like time series
or arrays for images, text
or video?
I'll answer first
and then you can go.
So one of the things that is
especially applicable in text
data is the a characteristic of
it is that it is really sparse.
And so one thing that we
did, have already integrated
is the ability to
internally within that loop
that we talked about past
data as a sparse matrix
to models that can
handle it and thus
train tune more effectively.
So this is something that we
definitely think about and are
interested in doing more of.
Do you want to add more
on survival analysis or.
Yeah, so for time
series and we've
mentioned Matt
Dancho's work, he's
here and has like a whole bunch
of packages that handle that.
You know, a lot of
times what we work on
is mostly about governed by what
we think, what we know about.
And honestly, I
don't think any of us
are expert at time series.
So Matt's stuff covers all of
that I think really, really
well we're doing more
with survival data
we'll be more widely integrated
with like tune and things
like that.
Hopefully by the end
of the year, we're
always on the look out, especially
for recipes in terms
of specialized things
that we can do.
Like, I'm not
making any promises,
but I used to work with a
lot of spectrometry data
and I don't do that anymore.
But in my mind, like,
that's the kind of data
would be great for a recipes
package, like specialized
recipes for that type
of data because they
have somewhat unique
data structures
and things they do to it.
So I think as time
goes on, we want
to find packages that satisfy
more niche, not markets,
but you know, niche
set of users that
would be really our
framework would be
do a really good
job of capturing.
Julia, could you comment on
how Vetiver compares and contrasts
with MLflow?
Sure I would say that
MLflow more highly
prioritizes model development in
having opinionated requirements
on how you develop your model.
It then does some
similar things in that
it provides a way for
you to deploy your model.
One thing that is
different about Vetiver
is that it is more flexible
in how you train your model,
how you tune your model.
If you've come from a more
statistical background,
you're going to be more
comfortable with using
your solid statistical
approaches to training
your model.
And then what Vetiver does
is it comes in at that point
once your model is trained.
So I highlight that
as a main difference
between the approach of MLflow
and the approach of Vetiver.
Max, how would a newcomer
get started with tidymodels?
Or do you think
this is something
that's only suitable for
seasoned data scientists?
No, it's definitely, I
think, relevant for anybody.
You know, it's a
little bit more verbose
than things like caret, you
might end up writing a few more
lines of code.
But its simplicity in
a way, is a lot more
it's a lot lower than,
let's say, caret,
because you don't have for
the one thing you want to do.
You don't have 75
options to sort through.
So I think it's really
good for newcomers,
especially if you
don't have, you know,
we've shown UMAP and
racing and things like that.
We don't want to make it
seem like you can't just
fit your LM model to
whatever equivalent
we're like mtcars
or something you have
that's like not
terribly complex.
So you can use it for that.
You can use it.
It's not necessarily
like optimized
for inferential models,
but we have a lot of things
that you can use for that.
For example, like
multi-level models,
like hierarchical Bayesian
models and mixed models.
We have infrastructure for that.
It's, you know, the scope of
it is a lot wider than maybe
what we demonstrated here.
But yeah, it's
pretty much usable
for like simple
things for newcomers
and, and then it lets you do
more and more as you go on.
So definitely if you're
new, I'd start off
with the Get Started part
of tidymodels.org
and that'll probably do a good
job of leveling you up there.
For both of you.
Any plans to integrate tidymodels
with causal inference
with causal inference.
Causal inference.
Casual inference, maybe.
Yeah, just casual.
Just casual.
This is actually something,
you know, of all the workshops
that we just had
the two days, that's
the one I would have liked
to have gone to the most
if I wasn't teaching one.
So, I don't know, maybe,
maybe we'll learn about it
and then start.
I don't know.
What do you think?
So I'd like to.
I was saying the same thing
at the book signing, you know.
Oh, what workshop do you go to?
And they say, look,
causal inference like
are their slides on github?
Again, it's like, you know,
the really great thing
about this job is like if
we don't, if there's a field
that we're not really
intimately acquainted with,
we can take the time
and learn that, right?
And so like, it's
something I always
want to learn more about.
I would very much like to,
there's a lot of methods,
especially, strangely
on the machine
learning side that have causal
versions of certain models.
So it definitely
piques my interest,
but I don't know much about
it, but I could definitely
see us doing that.
Maybe not this year,
but and also, you know,
we have a user survey that
we make about once a year,
so we put things on there
and let people vote.
We're not really bound
to those results,
but it really in the
past has really driven
some of our development.
So that's also a
way, if you want
to suggest some things to do
it when we do the next user
survey.
I think that's all the time
we have for questions now.
If you have other
questions, do not
ask them of Max because he is
leaving to get married now.
You can ask them on Discord.
I'll check Discord
like tomorrow,
maybe.
Thanks, Max.
Thanks, Julia.
And please enjoy the
rest of the conference.
Thank you.